de chica fui una buena alumna una buena
hija me encantaba jugar el hockey jugaba
de 5 no era de esos mediocampistas
habilidosos sino los de garra y corazón
mi vida transcurría sin demasiadas
preocupaciones ni altibajos hasta debo
confesar que por momentos me sentía un
poquitito laura ingalls
pero el 6 de agosto de 2002 a las siete
menos diez de la mañana sonó el
despertador paridad del colegio estaba
en quinto año el invierno de noche de
esos días fríos en los que uno sólo
quiere taparse hasta acá y seguir
durmiendo
salí de la cama de unos pasos pero mis
piernas se aflojaron y me caí al piso no
dije nada fui a desayunar y cuando quise
agarrar la taza con mi mano mi mano se
abrió y el café se cayó
que estaba pasando porque no podía
controlar mi cuerpo
así como esa mañana estalló la taza de
café también estalló mi vida mi rutina y
por un tiempo a mi alegría médicos
médicos médicos y más médicos de sacar
sangre todas las semanas estudios
estudios estudios y más estudios porque
nadie lograba decirme que era lo que
tenía pero eso fue hasta que llegué a lo
de la doctora eminencia
entre a su consultorio me recibió su
secretaria me hizo la ficha médica y me
invitó a sentarme en ese consultorio
había más niños que en el cine en
vacaciones de invierno
cuando me tocó pasar la doctora
eminencia me recibió sentada detrás de
su escritorio con todos los títulos a
sus espaldas empezó a mirar los análisis
que yo le había llevado y me dijo te voy
a pedir que estira los brazos palmas y
hacia arriba que te toques la punta de
la nariz con el índice derecho ahora con
el índice izquierdo ahora más rápido
ahora con los ojos cerrados
natalie tener epilepsia bio crónica
juvenil a partir de ahora vas a tener
que tomar medicación todas las mañanas y
todas las noches cada seis meses te vas
a tener que hacer un
electroencefalograma de sueño de esos
que uno duerme con todos los cables
conectados para ver si la epilepsia
sigue o se fue y te voy a decir los tres
no esta enfermedad no anticonceptivos no
alcohol y no pocas horas de sueño por
receta o cualquier cosa que necesite
lolas con mi secretaria eso es todo
muchas gracias
eso es todo
epilepsia crónica juvenil yo tenía 17
años y lo primero que pensé en ese
momento es esto es para cuando sea vieja
no es para ahora
al poco tiempo había engordado 8 kilos
me había llenado de granos y no me
sentía nada bien así que junté coraje y
volví a lo de la doctora eminencia y
cuando le expliqué lo que sentía lo que
me estaba pasando lo único que atinó a
decirme fue sí es verdad es la
medicación preferido decirte nada por si
no tenía estos efectos pero igual es la
mejor la tenés que seguir tomando
nuevamente muchas gracias por todo
quien no pasó alguna vez por un doctor
eminencia esos que no te miran a la cara
que pareciera que uno puso los síntomas
en google y salió un diagnóstico que ni
se dieron cuenta que pasaste por su
consultorio
la verdad yo no dudo que la doctora
eminencia era una excelente neurólogo
pero a mí me había tratado con un caso
más del libro
a los 3 años decidí cambiar de médica y
esta vez yo era la doctora clara
nuevamente lo mismo te voy a persistir
estos brazos palmas hacia arriba que te
toques la punta de la nariz con el
índice derecho con el índice izquierdo
más rápido con los ojos cerrados pero de
repente a lo cambio apoyo los análisis
que le habían llevado en el escritorio y
me dijo contamos un poco de voz que
haces a qué te dedicas que te gusta
hacer
me dijo que es verdad que la aplicación
que yo estaba tomando era la mejor pero
que podíamos probar con la segunda mejor
porque yo apostaba que de esa manera yo
también iba a estar bien
me dio pistas de qué hacer si me sentía
de tal o cual manera o si la medicación
no daba el resultado que esperábamos
pero lo que fundamentalmente la doctora
clara me explicó en que las epilepsias
es importante tener en cuenta lo que
emocionalmente le pasa al paciente
porque no no puede separar la enfermedad
de la identidad como no podemos separar
el cerebro de la mente
una misma persona soy yo una misma
enfermedad que fue la epilepsia mía
crónica juvenil pero que podría haber
sido cualquier otra y dos feedbacks dos
devoluciones completamente distintas
para la doctora eminencia yo no había
sido más que un caso de libro un número
más en su en ahorro mi fichero de
pacientes y su devolución lo único que
hizo fue concentrarse en todo lo que yo
no podía hacer con esta enfermedad
para la doctora clara sobre una persona
había empatizado conmigo se había
propuesto escucharme y ella que intentó
que esa oportunidad de diálogo que tuvo
conmigo pudiera resultar en un
aprendizaje
me resulta muy interesante pensar como
dos personas quejarse en la misma
profesión que estudiaron lo mismo pueden
ser completamente distintas y esto es un
caso de la medicina pero lo podemos
pensar en cualquier ámbito profesional o
de nuestras vidas cuántas veces nos
encontramos en entrevistas de trabajo en
reuniones en cursos con esos
profesionales o eminencias que lo único
que quieren es contarte lo que saben
transmitir del manual y no están
preocupados por escuchar por empatizar y
por entre todos tratar de buscar una
solución en conjunto
en mi caso me dedico a la educación
entre otras cosas doy clases en la
universidad para futuros docentes si
pensamos esto en términos educativos
podríamos decir que la doctora eminencia
me evaluó y me calificó me dijo natalie
vos sos un 6 estás aprobada y que pase
el que sigue
en cambio la doctora clara lo que hizo
fue invitarme a no pensar en esa nota
ella me dio una devolución me dio
información específica sobre en qué
cosas yo estaba fallando y que podía
hacer si yo quería mejorar
la verdad
yo no sé qué hacen mis alumnos con las
devoluciones que les doy
de la misma manera que creo que clara no
sabía lo que iba a hacer yo con lo que
me dijo ese día
pero lo que sí sé es que trato de hacer
siempre menos eminencia y más clara
porque estoy convencida que una buena
devolución es una oportunidad para
aprender
y quien dice nos puede cambiar la vida
[Aplausos]
[Música]